nature publishes a second paper on an
ancient Greek mystery the Antikythera
mechanism this promises to revolutionize
our understanding of the history of
technology and astronomy and it even
tells us about the timetable for the
earliest Olympic Games
the Antikythera mechanism would be
remarkable even if it was a less clever
thing than it is because there is so
little like it physically preserved or
even described in ancient books if it
hadn't been discovered when it was in
1901 no one would possibly believe that
it could exist because it's so
sophisticated it is in a sense you could
describe it as being the technological
side of the Greek miracle that created
so much of our Western civilization from
the mind that Mike Edmonds came to me
one day he's professor of astronomy at
carnac University and he said have you
ever heard of the Antikythera mechanism
I said no I hadn't you know what is it
he told me this extraordinary story in
1900 just off the coast of the small
island of Antikythera a group of sponge
divers came across the remains of an
ancient wreck the first diver to come to
the surface said he found a heap of dead
naked people underwater
second diver came up with a
larger-than-life bronze arm and what
they'd in fact discovered was the wreck
of a Roman merchant vessel stuffed full
of Greek treasure and all this treasure
was taken to the National Archaeological
Museum in Athens including a small dump
just over 30 centimetres high completely
disregarded at the time it lay in the
museum for some months according to
accounts and then it spit apart and when
it spit apart a curator noticed the
remnants of some small precision gear
wheels after the first half century
research which led to some insights but
generally a lot of confusion a British
physicist in the mid-1950s started to
study the mechanism he was called Derek
de Sala price-price was the first to
study x-rays of some of the fragments
made by Karel Ambus coracle us from
these x-rays Pryce developed a model of
how the mechanism worked it incorporated
one feature an ancient cycle of the Sun
and Moon called the metonic cycle which
was absolutely critical to later
understanding it's one of the basic keys
for understanding how the mechanism
works he also identified in the
mechanism some epicyclic gearing that is
to say gears that move with their axes
moving on other gears a completely
astonishing revelation for ancient
Greece now the very latest techniques
have been used to explore the mystery
device in the autumn of 2005
from hewlett-packard led by Tom malts
bender came with a special mechanism for
looking at the surfaces of all the
fragments with our method we photograph
a surface like this stone surface here
with a fixed camera but light sources at
multiple positions and from this we can
certainly interactively change lighting
conditions of the object on the computer
to bring out more detail but more
importantly what we can do is we can
change the reflectance properties the
the material base of the object itself
we can now transform into a very
metallic look this is we wanted 3d x-ray
information at high resolution also and
a world leading company called X
TEKsystems came with a team led by Roger
Hagglund they bought an eight-ton x-ray
machine to Athens so they produce
brilliant data we have absolutely
extraordinary high resolution data of
all 82 fragments of the mechanism and
this is being really the basis of many
of our revelations the Antikythera
mechanism was the ancestor of a whole
range of medieval instruments and clocks
Don unlined master instrument maker has
already made replicas of many devices
including the 14th century wallingford
clock his latest ambition is to make a
working version of the Antikythera
machine but all the gears they're all
squashed into quite an era you know like
your for Richard and Wally Vince clock
he left plenty of space between them but
in this I was surprised little by little
took up once once you get to the main
body of it you'll see the gears coming
up in slices because you know we took an
eight-ton x-ray machine to Athens to
x-ray little-to-no and we did it in 3d
so we could get the three-dimensional
information
out of the other she's coming and you're
just beginning to see now the crown miss
your physician series music advance was
it not from from it of your earlier well
that's love you see you can see the
gears and legs it's exactly where they
are in their relationship in three
dimensions which is what price didn't
have of course like no no you couldn't
see the three-dimensional arrangement of
it is that's the gear price identified
is 120/70 unit with anatomic site
this is 223 T it was a red light and so
on and that those are years
that's the little pin and slop that
might identify but let me show you so
this is a computer animation of the
gears love lending it's a beautiful
thing isn't it
it goes around very quickly obviously
because otherwise you I've got the moon
work on there's that's a little moon
phase indicator that Michael Wright
identified beautiful device here we've
got it on the wallingford clock very
similar very similar but over fourteen
hundred years later fact you can see if
we look at the back of fragments see
that's the little ball there people had
seen this for a hundred years and it
took Michael rights to to resolve it he
said that's what it is and it's the sort
of thing you think yes of course it is